hello not bad man I remember because I'm
bad man today we're gonna look at one of
the greatest enemy it shows that ever
hit television Batman the Animated
Series by the way you wait a little more
than hundred eight okay I'm sorry I
can't do keep very well oh let's try a
Christian Bale mm-hmm this cartoon just
showed you that's full of people ready
to believe in God okay it's not gonna
work
let's try about Kilmer mmm-hmm okay it's
right through okay it's definitely not
gonna happen
let's try George Clooney hi I'm George
Clooney okay fuck this shit I'm just
going as myself yes I've gone on record
several times saying that Batman the
Animated Series is the best nostalgic
show ever as well as one of the best
cartoons of all time it was dark it was
tragic it was funny it was goofy it was
serious it had something for everybody
but which episode were the absolute best
which ones left the greatest impact on
us whether it be action-packed
or dramatically heartbreaking there's a
lot to choose from and I promise I'll
try to keep my spoilers to a minimum
except maybe this one Batman and Robin
socks really downside is I don't have
any more Batman's to imitate oh wait a
minute
Kevin Conroy that's fitting well ballet
just takes that much just not some pills
here mmm
whoa my testicles just hit the floor
this is the top 11 best Batman animated
series episodes
I don't wear hockey pants
[Music]
number eleven beware a great ghost
though a good episode a lot of it holds
up particularly well because of the
celebrity voice they use but I'll get to
the end a second the episode centers
around an old TV show called the Grey
Ghost that Bruce Wayne used to watch as
a kid years later it turns out some
psycho is imitating one of the villains
from the show and since all the episodes
were destroyed Batman goes to the star
himself the Gray Ghost for help I'm just
an actor the Gray Ghost was a part I
played the bombings in Gotham are
exactly like an episode of the Gray
Ghost I need you to remember how it was
done it's a good episode because it's a
decent mystery it's neat to see Bruce
Wayne's inspiration as well as actually
some happy flashbacks to his childhood
and it also shows the dramatic downside
to both having and losing thing although
I will admit it's a little weird to see
Batman actually go fanboy for somebody
and when your kid is one thing but the
idea of Batman The Dark Knight having a
little shrine in his Batcave dedicated
to a TV show
Jesus Batman you're a dork as a kid I
used to watch you with my father the
great ghost was my hero now give me a
lock of your hair
I'm totally gonna smell it every night
but what really makes the episode stand
out is who they got to play the great
ghost none other than the original TV
Batman himself Adam West like you said
you need my help rather than just make a
funny little joke that - bad Mans are in
the same show
they actually demonstrate a lot of
dignity in having these two together and
even cleverly mirror some of the
realities that really did go on with the
original Batman shows never to a point
where it's insulting or it satirical I
used to admire what the Gray Ghost stood
for I'm not the Gray Ghost I can see
that now
it was a real respect to this team and
it shows and just how much effort the
writers and directors put into it we
became passionate about the episode
because they became passionate about the
energy to bad news for the price of one
what's not to like
[Music]
some days you just can't get rid of a
bomb
number 10 the man who killed Batman
this one gets overlooked a lot but it
really is a gem a little twerp nameless
Quinn wants to make a name for himself
as a big-time gangster but nobody wants
him because he's a timid little screw-up
why did you bring along that Louie he's
useless not his bait for Batman you'll
be too busy kicking the crud out of CID
to notice us but it turns out he
stumbles upon a bit of luck when he
accidentally knocks Batman off a cliff
and apparently kills him get away anyway
don't assign Sid the squid just off the
Batman suddenly he's the most notorious
criminal in town and everybody is in all
of his accomplishment suddenly I'm
thinking if I take down the guy who took
down Batman then I'll be the toughest
guy in town hey it got my vote chief but
again with that Fame comes a price
people start to challenge into fights
others try to murder him even the Joker
seems mighty pissed off that there's no
more fun to be had with the mythical
Dark Knight this is certain rhythm to
these things I caused trouble he shows
up we have some laughs and the game
starts all over again without Batman
crime has no punch line there's an
especially funny scene where the Joker
actually throws a funeral for Batman and
of course it's totally keeping in
character it's time to look ahead to a
future filled with smiles just as soon
as we take that man there and slap him
in that box there and roll it into that
vat of acid man and for the record
Harley's kazoo playing is nowhere near
as good as paws kazoo play
it's a classic case of a person who
wanted fame and attention but wasn't
ready for the pain and responsibility
that came with it no one's that lucky or
stupid yes I am the story is great the
seas with the joker are hilarious and
actor Matt Frewer as the squid really
makes a perfect comic foil oh sorry
about the leather hood it's a perfectly
told tale of what happens when too much
recognition comes to the wrong person at
the wrong time guess I can't win for
losing huh mad love one of the show's
crowning achievements was the creation
of Harley Quinn has since become many
people's favorite Batman character we've
never actually known her history they've
hinted at it before and dropped Clues
here and there but they've never given
us the straight up details about how she
ended up with the Joker well this is the
episode that sets it all straight it
turns out Harley was an intern at arkham
asylum and was looking to cash in on one
of the high-profile criminals to write a
tell-all book about we can't deny
there's an element of glamour to these
super criminals I'll warn you right now
these are hardcore psychotics if you're
thinking about cashing in on them think
again when she started interviewing the
Joker he played to her weaknesses and
his mind game slowly started to sink in
and just like The Dark Knight we have no
idea if his past story is the real one
or a false one my father used to beat me
up pretty badly
every time I got out of line bat and one
night he goes half crazier than usual
it's also the first time we get a very
strong indicator that the Joker and
Harley have well made whoopee cushion I
mean it was hinted at before but this
seemed pretty much cements that they've
been together don't you want to rev up
your Harley because of that we see in
more detail just how violent the
relationship is between the two of them
and how the Joker is and always has used
her as just a means to an end
you've forgotten what I told you a long
time ago
you always take shots from folks who
just don't get the joke and don't call
me puddin it's actually a pretty tragic
look at abusive relationships in general
at no matter just how tormenting one can
be to another
there's only something that keeps the
other coming back from war yeah there's
quite a bit of fanservice and I don't
know why the Joker looks like Mickey
Mouse but it's still a solid episode
that finally fills us in with all the
questions we had about our favorite
Hedgehog and it didn't disappoint with
the answers
[Music]
birds of a feather this is another one
that's often overlooked the penguin
who's considered one of the more
sophisticated of the criminals decides
he wants to change his way and become a
civilized bird once he makes parole and
he means it he actually starts to change
his ways and tries to blend in as an
average citizen he finds though that
nobody's waiting for him and nobody's
happy for his return especially Ben I've
reformed wherever you go I'll be right
behind you
but it turns out an extremely rich woman
named Veronica wants to date the penguin
so she can make the headlines by
inviting him to her party
why for the entertainment dodo can't you
just see their faces when that stuff
cape on waddles in she's pretty much
dating a mezack joke just a means to get
attention from other rich people she
quickly finds though they concede as
charming as she thought well it's pretty
fucking gross but the attention she's
giving is far too much for her to pass
up
while she's dating him mostly to make
fun of him the penguin takes it very
seriously and even starts to fall in
love with her and after an incident
where he saves her life even she starts
to see a little bit of good at him you
know it was quite touching actually it's
not often that a man rushes to my rescue
unfortunately he wants to see me again
but like all tragic tales the truth is
revealed at just the wrong moment which
causes the Penguins heart to be broken
and returned back to his villainous ways
the episode is actually very similar to
another one called Harley's holidays
where Harley Quinn starts a new life for
herself finds a hard to fit in and also
tragically gets thrown back to her old
ways this one takes its time a little
bit
it shows how involved the penguin really
got into the relationship and how close
he really was to turning over a new leaf
it's more detailed it's more cruel and
therefore more sad not only does the
penguin almost truly perform himself
Muraki almost does too and if it didn't
all spawn from such a cruel joke
maybe both these people could have
turned out to be better I really was
growing fond of you it's too bad this
had to happen
I suppose it's true what they say
society is to blame high society it's a
tale of what could have been and what
shouldn't be done
[Music]
Merson two-face consumed one of the most
depressing of the Batman villas Harvey
two-face Dent is a criminal with a deep
and complex backstory he suffers from an
extreme split personality which causes
him to flip-flop from a kind intelligent
politician there's so few - a
bloodthirsty monster who lunches out at
random he has bad dreams here's the
voice in his head and at the worst-case
scenario he actually becomes the other
personality I would like to talk with
big bad Harv
I don't think he wants to talk please
try big bad Harv speaking what makes
this character so good in the show is
that the transformation episode isn't
the first time we see Harvey they've
actually established him several
episodes before he hangs out with Bruce
Wayne goes on dates helps out the
Commissioner so he was a completely set
of character that we really got to like
so when this episode came out it was a
genuine shock to see the demons he was
battling if anyone's leaving its mr.
goody-good did I do this instead of acid
being flown in his face we have an
explosion that destroys half of his body
Cena's character permanently lose
himself to the other personality is just
gut-wrenching throw in a tragic
Hollywood effect he had a fiance and on
top of that we even have the guilt that
Batman feels for not being able to save
his best friend I mean just look at some
of these dream sequences Harvey please
let me help you
[Music]
why couldn't you save us son yes ma'am
could you throw like a happy face in
there or something why couldn't you save
us son the angles are great the shadows
are great the animation is great it's
just a great end us to face it's just
another addition to the lost souls that
makes this show so friggin hardcore it's
time RV it's dying number six
over the edge now with a title like that
you know some shit has to go down in
this episode and boycotted dogs get a
lot of this opening it starts out with
Batman and Robin being chased by
Commissioner Gordon and his men trying
to gun them down right after they arrest
Alfred and the award for best what the
fuck opening goes to that I mean holy
fuck that's one hell of a way to start
out but that's nothing that's just the
intro every holy shit moment you can
imagine happens right after this we find
out in a flashback that because of a
fight with the Scarecrow Batgirl gets
killed smashes into her father's car and
Gordon then finds out that she was his
daughter the whole time trust you you
never told me
he quickly discovers who Batman is goes
full force and taking him down Nightwing
is taken to jail
Robin is told to turn himself in Gordon
even makes a deal with Bane to go after
Batman knowing he'll show up to his
daughter's funeral good fucking eat hell
there's no place to run wait I want him
alive
alive to run away in Arkham surrounded
by the monsters he's created how can
anyone not like a setup like this it's
intense it's action pack it's just
awesome now the problem that most people
have with this episode is the ending
yeah I'd be lying if I said I thought it
wasn't a bit of a cop-out to I don't
know maybe it's because we could all see
it coming and I guess we sort of thought
they'd throw up better twist on top of
it but it's not one of the stronger
enemies
despite that though the majority the
episode still holds up pretty strong and
it's still a great one in story it's
dark it's brooding and the scenario is
pretty extreme and for those wondering
how the ending could have been improved
join me over at pic number 5
[Music]
number five
perchance to dream
this is if the over the edge episode was
fully realized no taking sort of an
opposite approach Bruce Wayne wakes up
one morning and finds that everything in
his life is truly changed for the best
parents are alive he's marrying the
woman he loves and there's even somebody
else who's doing the job of Batman
Selena does the name Catwoman
thing about Bruce you're beginning to
worry me what's this all about he can't
understand why and even though
everything is just how he's always
wanted it and even at one point starts
to accept it there's still a twinge of
darkness that won't let him leave it
alone no you're alive it's all alive is
it madness breaking through sanity or
sanity breaking through madness
questions keep knocking back and forth
in his head until it builds up to the
ultimate showdown Bruce Wayne versus is
alter ego Batman you're not well mr.
Wayne
you need to professional help
wire the way he finds out that
everything isn't as it seems is clever
but I still sort of question it what's
the episode to see what I'm talking
about
but still that's not what makes it good
what makes it good is not only his
longing to lead a normal life and his
actual enjoyment of it for a little
while but finding out just who is behind
all this and how it's being kept going
in fact if you listen to the musical
theme the answer is actually given to
you very early on
what it touches like that are great and
it's nice to see what Bruce Wayne's life
would have been like had it not been for
that one tragic night it builds up the
sadness and brings down the darkness
it's a dream that could never be and
even harder
[Music]
heart of ice
would you like how the show created
Harley Quinn they also recreated mr.
freeze keeping him a very different and
much darker backstory freezin this
version was originally as scientists
trying to find a cure for his deathly
ill wife who he has cryogenically frozen
to save her once he goes over budget
though his boss comes in to shut the
experiment down dooming his chances of
ever seeing her again
[Music]
freeze tries to fight them off but gets
knocked into a bunch of various
chemicals that do all those creative
things that a bunch of various chemicals
do in this case make it impossible for
him to live without being its sub-zero
temperatures it would move me to tears
if I still had tears to shed but that's
where the free suit comes from and
that's where it's cold outlook on the
world originates it can only beg your
forgiveness and pray you'll hear me
somehow someplace a warm hand waits for
mine the backstory was so good that now
everybody uses it the comics the graphic
novels the TV shows even Joel Schumacher
to his credit knew how powerful the
image of a frozen loved one still
doesn't excuse that which I'll never
never leave the cave without it don't
tell me clearly the imagery this episode
creates is always a memorable and often
duplicated it's the kind of surreal
imagery people love to use in Batman
stories and this is the episode that
started it all it may freeze more than
just a guy with a cool gun and made him
a Shakespearean tragedy the music as
well adds to the Cobb wonder that the
episode creates the atmosphere in every
respect is so heavy that the lines
practically write themselves to never
again walk on a summer's day with a hot
wind in your face and a warm hand to
hold oh yes for that a much better
alternative than freeze well that
nobody try this episode brings up
something that a lot of Batman fans have
brought up for a while with criminals
like the Joker twoface and Clayface it's
been doing more harm than he is good
half the time it seems like he's almost
created these buildings does it turn out
all along that Batman is actually the
cause of the majority of misery in
Gotham City well all the famous villains
get together to find out they take over
Arkham Asylum capture Batman and force
the new district attorney to represent
the only downside is wait those were all
downsides the district attorney thinks
Batman is just as guilty as the rest of
them not only this Batman create these
so-called super criminals he takes it
upon himself to be their judge and jury
with no regard for the legal system
these are very good points the issues
that appointed what Batman as well as
what any other superhero does for a long
time with the Joker as judge and
two-face as the prosecution the biggest
gathering of villains in the show's
history come together to see if they've
been wronged by Batman's vigilantism I
suppose you like your friends claim that
Batman droving to be a criminal
did you brainwashed and kidnapped a
woman who rejected you he was going to
take her away from me
you could have respected her wishes I
got killed a five it's a great episode
not just for the issues that raise it
but also for the fact that all of your
favorite villains are in the same room
and the conclusion that the villains
come to shows us once again why we love
these villains and why they're so
friggin interesting to watch it's a
great idea executed perfectly the
visuals are strong the lighting is
stylish and it's just so awesome to see
all your favorite band share the screen
together it's also great to see the DA
go to her own story our could come to
our own unique conclusion while trying
to juggle staying alive in the building
of crazies it's like a trial in
Wonderland you know it feels done right
trying to play to the sanity and order
with a world that has little to none of
the AVD evidene that
[Music]
baby doll many of you might remember my
crossover review with CR on familiar
faces with this episode's you can
probably get much more information about
it there but once again it's an episode
that is seriously overlooked it's about
an actress from a sitcom who has a rare
disease that keeps it from growing
taller she was born with systemic
hypoplasia a rare condition that kept
her from aging would you believe she was
20 years old in that clip crushed by the
fact that her career never went anywhere
she becomes deranged and psychologically
obsessed with getting the cast back
together and staying in her fictional
sitcom world Mary Dahl well this sounds
like a funny scenario and they do point
out the silliness of it quite often it
still keeps us grounded in what's
causing it it addresses the pain that
our villain is going through both with
the prejudices of being a little person
and being a celebrity especially an
out-of-work celebrity to a point where
you actually feel bad you were laughing
at her in earlier scenes they also
acknowledge that she made mistakes and
isolated her from her friends and that
she feels there's no other place that
will accept her anymore except in their
own demented imagination it was hard for
me out there I studied and trained an
audition but no one wanted me
over the years I remembered how happy I
was with all of you around me and the
folks at home watching me tweet me baby
down
maybe we dive into what it means to make
mistakes adjusting to them and having to
live with the changes in your identity
like many great Batman villain she comes
off as being creepy intimidating I'm
also kind of funny but it's the third
act that really becomes the emotional
tearjerker I won't give too much away
here but let's just say it's whether in
those heartbreaking moments in the
Batman series and given the lineup that
we've had on the show that's saying a
lot it's a great episode with a great
villain and a great ending it's easily
among one of the best best batman the
animated series episode is almost got
this is just a perfect episode the set
up what can I say it's incredible the
Joker the penguin two-face poison ivy
and croc are all playing poker together
that image alone is fantastic but it
gets interesting when they start betting
on who's come the closest to killing off
bat I've come the closest are you
kidding I was the one who nearly no
please come closer to snuffing the
Batman and me the fact of the matter is
we each have an almost dogged Batman
story
I know mine's the best but let's hear
yours anyway so each one tells their
tale about how they almost got it
the stories are creative the action is
strong in the ways they've almost done
him in actually are pretty damn
entertaining but it's the inner action
off one another that really makes this
one the best
half of me wants to strangle you and
what is the other
to hit you with a truck we used to date
ah it's not sad it's not tragic kids not
even really that dark it's just the
villains chilling out being the villains
and you know what that's pretty fucking
cool most people realize that the
strength of Batman comes half from him
and half from his opponents so the more
real and identifiable they are the more
drawn in we become this is the episode
where the villains seen the most human
they're not up to anything they're not
planning any evil schemes they're
displaying cards it's actually nice to
see them just relax and be themselves
and the dialogues they have are just
great including one of the funniest
moments in any of the shows anyone else
want to go there I was holed up in this
quarry when Batman came nosing around
and I threw a rock at him
it was a big draw it's also the first
time the show had five of the major
villains in one room this will be up
stage later with the trial episode but
for the time this was pretty frigging
awesome that we saw this it's sort of
like when all the villains got together
in the fat man it's just so cool to see
them working off each other
the writing is great the animation is
great the stories are great the builds
up to a bit of a twist at the end to
show that the episode actually did serve
a purpose outside of just seeing the bad
guy shoot the shit but like I said it's
the interaction of the bad guys that
makes it so perfect the way they work
off each other and even poke fun at each
other's flaws your end within my aviary
of what each how corny can you get it's
just an awesome episode and it makes
these characters seem surprisingly much
more 3-dimensional than if there was an
entire episode dedicated to one of them
it's just everybody doing what they do
and doing it at their best it's an
absolutely perfect episode almost Gotham
and those are my top 11 Batman the
Animated Series episodes one of the
greatest shows of all time now for those
of you who didn't see your favorite
episodes on the list here's my
runners-up there you go I'm the
Nostalgia Critic I remember it so you
don't have
[Music]
it was a big rod